the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night past
Studios I am Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com and Ryan sickler on all your
social media uh Happy New Year to
everybody out there I hope you had a
great holiday season and I hope this
2023 I hope you kick its [ __ ] ass all
right uh please subscribe to that
YouTube channel out there and um if you
need more then you gotta check out the
patreon I'm keeping it at five bucks we
haven't raised it once it's staying five
bucks all year if you want to save even
more money sign up for a year you're
getting a month free all right you get
the Honeydew a day early you're still
getting it ad free and you're getting it
at no additional cost all right also one
of those throw a little shout out to the
feasters the crab Feast is back uh we
got it uh back in our what do you call
it I don't know is it possession I don't
think it's possession it's just you know
under the artist control how's that
sound
um so if you don't know about the crab
Feast man you gotta check it out it's a
seven and a half year library of all
your favorite comedians in podcasting
with different stories all right we're
gonna keep putting links uh in the
episodes of people who were on the crab
Feast you can go ahead and check out an
episode and uh make sure you subscribe
to that as well alright if you love
Donnie do I promise you're gonna love
that and if you're all caught up on the
do you got a hell of a library to go
check out
all right now you guys know we do over
here we highlight the low lights all
right these are the stories behind the
storytellers and I'm very excited to
kick the year off with this guest who's
back on the do ladies and Gentlemen
please welcome Chappelle Lacey welcome
back to the new Chappelle thanks for
having me back thank you for being here
yeah of course man
um before we get into everything please
plug all of it all uh social medias uh
all of them are at Chappelle Lacy uh I
don't do Twitter or nothing like that a
little crazy right now uh and also uh
I'll be in uh Sacramento January 5th
through the 7th at uh the punch line
I've never done that that club before I
don't think I've ever been up to
Sacramento actually but uh yeah that's
pretty much
um for me and just yeah come see me on
the road and stuff yeah all right well
it's good to have you back yeah it's
good to be back man and um
you have if you haven't heard
Chappelle's first episode you gotta go
listen to your first episode so your
first episode we talked about uh you
were adopted by a white family in your
teens shout out to white people shout
out to white people whoa the one doing
the ones
the Sandra Bullocks and the timber girls
The Blind Side ones the blinds shout out
to The Blind Side white people no and Mr
Drummond Phil drums
how old were you when you were adopted
by them ah man that was so it was like
odd because it wasn't like um
uh
uh illegal adoption I was just but they
took me in they started taking care of
me when I was like 15 but 17 was when I
uh had moved in but but before we get
into that I got I gotta say something I
just wanted to recap no no you're good
you're good I gotta say something uh
that I've never really
felt before
uh until until I did that last episode
you you said something you said hey you
should go
read the the comments and I was like oh
no I you know I'd rather not you know I
don't really I don't want to partake in
that world you know because you used to
working on different shows
[Laughter]
some people like
I've always explained everything down
there there's still people to throw
grenades on mine too like yeah yeah and
people that listen to podcasts are just
so like they're just die-hard fans yeah
they are so they have a lot to say when
they listen to something every day every
week they have a lot to say so I was so
I you said that to me I was like yeah no
I'd rather I'd rather not and and you
you pushed me you said you might want to
check these out and so I did in in
that was that was the first time I ever
really felt um
I I I like I don't look for validation
ever or reassurance it's something that
that is never
needed in my world mainly because of
my stepfather my abusive stepfather this
is pre-adoption all that stuff
um growing up with him
you know everything so real quick let me
just go ahead because I want to make
sure people understand yeah your
biological dad was locked up prison
trying to murder shout out and then your
mom marries another man who is actually
never married but they were just
together but that's the man we're
talking about now that's the man I'm
talking about different from the father
different from the white people so black
people there we go I'll do it that way
so black family all right
uh yeah he he was he always told me
everything about me was incorrect
and
anything I ever did was bad even even
things like I I'm not saying I was a
great kid all the time but for the most
part I just like doing the things that I
loved which was skateboarding going to
punk and hardcore shows and and uh
cheerleading all these things were very
positive things to me that kept me out
of trouble I I didn't sell drugs I
didn't you know get locked get locked up
I didn't do anything of that drive I
didn't drink a driver anything of that
nature that was never never my style but
meanwhile
um
meanwhile he made me feel like
everything was incorrect so
so I I kind of built this thing into me
to where
if that's if that's how a person sees me
then and I I don't know I just thought
the rest of the world also saw me that
way because
when you're a kid and that's the adult
that's in the house it's this is
supposed to be your parent and they tell
you these things you tend to believe it
because that's the person you live with
that's the person you see every day got
me on the hook for Jesus you got me on
the hook for God Santa the Easter Bunny
the Tooth Fairy yeah I'm gonna believe
this yeah
I'm riding with you on everything else
everybody here exactly so so
I think growing up and realizing that
early on I've kind of just forget what
people say I don't care what people say
whether it's good or bad I just I just
don't I just didn't never cared so the
the kindness of the people in that
comment section on that episode
was was insane to me it gave it like
when I was reading it it gave me an
energy that I just never felt before
from people saying
really nice things about me and for that
it being a lot of people because not
saying that what my stepfather said was
like stuck in my head and like you know
just ruined me I think I've just never
you know just cared for what many people
really
say like have said about me you know
because it just I don't know he I mean
he messed me up pretty damn bad but
for people to say that and say the
things that they were saying I was it
really caught me off guard and I know at
the end of the day I'm just a I'm just a
guy that's just trying every day to just
deliver myself yeah look man I want to
say this I want to give a shout out to
everyone out there this fan base
I'm very fortunate they're great people
yeah like I said there's a few you know
lunatics on everybody's Squad everybody
but uh you know there's that guy on your
that roots for your team you're like why
you gotta root for our team man yeah
but we'll take your money though bro
we'll take your money we got you at the
parking lot yeah
um
but it's like um I don't know when
people [ __ ] ride you like that and
you get used to it it's like you're you
know I'm with you I never looked for
validation the the it was always like
wearing this jacket this jacket of this
person's putting on me every day you
ain't [ __ ] you this you're you're a
[ __ ] loser you'll never be anything
like not just killing me today telling
me it ain't worth nothing from the rest
of the record
every [ __ ] yeah and then you don't
believe it you fight it the thing that
helped me was I was good at sports I was
good in school and I started to see like
well wait a second I'm doing better than
these kids who have two parents
yeah and I was like okay so Talent is
different than anything than being loved
but self-belief that's where it's
[ __ ] yeah believing the whole time I
believe and then with you I don't mean
to stop no no you're good there have
been moments in my life where if you
don't look look for it it might take 20
years but that [ __ ] comes around and
then all of a sudden you get to take
that [ __ ] jacket off like I
didn't know this one right here was an
option yeah put that on you're like God
damn this feels good and that comment
section [ __ ] dressed you up man it
really did because
um
yeah I've always been really talented at
the things that I've done but I've never
thought of it as like yeah I'm talented
at this I just it's just things that I
love to do and I just I just put it out
there and so
for that kind of posit positive feedback
or for just me telling my story what
you've overcome where you are now it's
kind of wild
it was just wild I just never never felt
that
you know and like I said I'm just a guy
you know
sorry don't be
foreign
take your time
I'm just the guy that's like uh
it's always trying to deliver my best
so
but I've always just kept that to myself
you know
and uh
I just kind of lived in my own world
so for people to really uh
you know feel something from words that
I'm saying
it's a
especially when I know where I come from
you know
uh it's wild uh
get a response
uh
like that you know I just never think
about
I just never think about that
it's crazy it's crazy uh it's called
love especially yeah
especially especially in the world today
man like you're like yes yeah what is
this like damn this is what this feels
like oh positivity yeah they got me on
this side this Full House moment
dead grandmother's teeth out of the
goddamn carpet crying on my [ __ ]
hands and knees like I got nobody in my
life I can even ask for a dollar yeah
and to get positivity and love from this
show to have people people tell me they
reconnected with family they have
started therapy that this show Saved
their life and I tell every before I
start every stand-up show I'm like y'all
are doing the same thing for me you
really are and I don't know that they
know that that the connection that I
feel from that and I'm giving back I
don't know that they feel that either
you know what I mean I hope they know I
say it all the [ __ ] time this is the
best fan base in comedy there's no doubt
yeah I mean people tell me that they go
on shows that are much bigger than the
show but the reaction that they get from
the fan base is way more from this show
and it's positive uh than a lot of shows
they do yeah yeah it's yeah like I said
like especially just because the world
we live in today you know like if we
make it we make it very very tough for
ourselves just to exist sometimes you
know and I mean we we go so hard on just
us as humans all the time so
you know especially on these social
media platforms you know people people
like to people like to say some [ __ ] you
know they love this they love to say
some [ __ ] keyboard Cowboy yeah and it's
like damn everybody just like hey
everybody everybody at the end of the
day I think is really trying their best
and not everybody
they're not some people aren't I say all
the time too look I'm you remind me a
lot of of me when I was younger like
Angry as [ __ ] yeah and but full of love
uh bit broey but emotionally displacing
my [ __ ] trying to figure it all out
gather it in and and also always giving
your best [ __ ] effort yeah it didn't
matter I've said for years I used to
joke but I meant it like be the best
wherever the [ __ ] you are yeah if you're
in Community College
go to division one yeah Community
College yeah that's how I feel without
when I was a valet like I was like I
want to be the best Bellman valet that I
can [ __ ] be and meanwhile that's made
me that's transitioned into to the world
of comedy and you know since I've gone
full time that's right I haven't had to
work in nine to five but yeah I think a
lot of people strive to be the best and
and instead of just the best they can be
yeah you know yeah yeah yeah I just want
to be good at this thing I want to be
good whatever [ __ ] shell and
computers right here I want to make this
machine the best thing it can be yeah
especially
just because I was so damn angry like I
told you before
yeah I've had three I've had three
different anger management teachers so
I want to talk about that because you
also told me that you talked to your mom
about this last episode as well right
yeah my mom and I my this biological mom
black family back to black flame got it
uh her and I didn't necessarily have the
our my relationship with my mom wasn't
hectic
but it wasn't great there was just no
substance to
my mom and I at all and not really
realizing that she was going through
[ __ ]
with the dude she was with at the time
yeah we were both going through the same
[ __ ] but obviously we just never talked
about it and uh
our relationship now it's insane we we
talk on such a deep level
that it's happening what started that
and when did that start so that that
actually started in 2013 when my brother
had passed my my he was on my only
full-blooded uh sibling
um and what happened to him he died of
an overdose an overdose yeah that uh
accidental overdose he how old was he he
was 28. he was 28 and I was 26 at the
time and so when my brother
he was probably one of the most
significant people in my life because we
went through hell together as kids
because the thing about our stepfather
um we weren't his kids right and he
obviously had this
you know
he didn't like he didn't like our
biological father at all right and so I
don't know I I would have to ask him
um
why did that but he treated my brother
and I completely
different so he did have kids with your
mom yes and then how many uh
uh four four four sorry sorry okay yeah
yeah sorry but you two were like yeah
yeah we were not yes and he'd make that
very clear
that he'd make that very clear was he
abusive to everyone though not you know
like was you're also abusive to your
brother my my brother that passed yeah
yeah
we had it we had it we had a divorce for
sure you know I mean he's just what he
want a good dad yeah in general you know
but
yeah he was he was he was aggressive to
to my brother and I pretty pretty heavy
so losing my brother and my brother was
like my protector
you know every day you know because we
we were going through that crazy [ __ ] at
home so anybody that would mess with us
outside like there's times I would get
in fights right and before I could even
swing
he was already there I go let me let me
come on let me let me have my turn let
me let me let me get my hits like I get
that you're there you know but like I
was like I know how to fight too
everyone's like yo your brother keeps
saving you [ __ ] like that but you know
shout out to my brother you know rest
his soul but uh but it was beautiful now
that I think about it and we we were
just we were just so close we and so to
lose him
I don't know I don't know what to do
with my world
I got I got very very depressed
um and I saw the side of my mom here's
where the reconnecting happens I saw
this side of my mom
that I just saw I it was the first time
I really saw her pain
and because meanwhile growing up she was
just so quiet
in reserved but I never saw her
I don't even think I had seen my mom
crying at that time but she was just
very quiet and reserved and so
um
I actually saw pain in her this time
this is her first born yeah she loses
him and
um
there was just something in my soul that
just said be there for her
and and so I just started doing that I
just started being there for her and
ever since that um
can like that just doing that giving
that much
um just eased up a lot of things and we
were able to talk about
a lot of things that we never really
talked about before what sticks out
um the biggest thing that sticks out was
when my stepfather had kicked me out
there's still black side uh how old are
you black side
who kicks you out uh I was 16 or 17 when
he had kicked me out yeah yeah or yeah
17 some somewhere around there and I
remember
that was that was a crazy day but it was
the happiest day of my life I was like
damn all right I'm out of here and uh he
uh I remember my mom had worked the
overnight shift at the hospital and she
just had pulled up and she saw my
stepfather standing over my
you know because he packed he packed all
my clothes and put it in trash bags and
he's she saw him standing over and then
me going to collect my bags and then
leaving and she was just crying it's
just after your brother died uh
uh notice before this before my brother
yeah because I was 17 he died at 28.
that was and yo that actually that was
the first time I saw her cry it was when
I got kicked out I'm wondering oh my God
this guy's kicking out her son after her
other son died but it was before no it
was before that and so yeah that was the
first time I ever saw her cry that was
yeah and I asked the question yeah yeah
yeah it's good thank you thank you and
uh what did that make you feel like
because you say it's happy as [ __ ]
you're out like fine I was out but also
now you're watching your mom that was
that initial emotion
I didn't even think about my mom crying
I just told her I said I'll be fine I'll
be fine I didn't know I was gonna be
fine I didn't know what I was gonna do
uh but I was like I'll be I'll be fine I
I I got this and uh she talked and years
later fast forward to us reconnecting
she told me
the day he had kicked me out
that's when she was planning her Escape
that's when it was a wrap for her which
I didn't know and even though she had
four kids with him yep she was she she
was gonna get get out get the rest of
them and get out and and I didn't know
that I didn't know that until she told
me that yeah when we were talking one
day like meanwhile I'm living here this
was like maybe two years ago she had
said that and I I never knew that in
that was uh it gave me this other layer
of love for my mom it's like oh you felt
that way when he I didn't know how she
felt when he kicked me out I mean I saw
her I saw her crying but I I don't think
I locked into that no there's there's no
way in hell I did
um
because I did I didn't really talk to
her after that
but oh really yeah we I couldn't I
couldn't hold a strong conversation the
most we were talking it'd be like a
three-minute conversation where'd you go
uh that's when I uh with the white folks
okay you went there right away so we're
moving on now you had a place
they're like George Louisiana
[Laughter]
yep I used to just live in hallways with
the rooms
I lived in a space
so yeah that's that's where I went but
to hear her say that that's how she felt
after after that fact it just made me
feel
the strong love for her
just like damn that's my mom how does
she feel about your adopted family oh
she loves him okay she always asks about
them all the time all right yeah she
asked about them all the time like I
said they didn't live too far from each
other it was like 20 minutes down the
road okay yeah so I could have walked
home anytime but I was just like I like
these stairs
nobody's throwing me down right now
hahaha
yeah I'm walking up and downstairs hell
yeah thank you white people appreciate
that
thank you for these days man I never had
stairs but that's nice
so I I mean that's that's the
there's just so much Beauty in life that
if you just really lock into it and pay
attention to it you you you
I don't know you find these things that
that'll just move you forward and help
you become at peace
what a what a lot of [ __ ] and like I
said I had I had three different anger
management yeah
was that a suggested thing or no they
they put me there but they always say
you're strong listen they always did
this is what I hate about this [ __ ] this
is what makes you mad they're always
like well you put yourself here I go no
no you walked me in here all right so
who's they and what how did you choose
the first time the first time I was 15
when I went to anger management are you
you're still so you're still with
stepdad yeah yeah yeah all right yeah uh
what happened
so I got
so what I used to get picked on for
being the black kid that listened to
punk rock and skated and all that stuff
and I remember one time this is the
white kids who listened to Pumpkin
but you were dead yeah I was I was an
outlier and so there was this guy he
kept calling me a wankster one day I
just I just started High School it was
that just started high school and he was
calling me that because he was just
everybody would say something smart
about it did you still have this size
right here you were stocky bill I wasn't
this I wasn't like this stocky but I was
like yeah I was shredded and um
I remember one day I was just like I'm
gonna just fight this kid I swear and I
remember one time he said it again and
then I I went after him I was like hey
man like it just went crazy and like I I
would go
an extra mile just to fight and I used
to do this thing where I would like take
my fist and I would go bam like that
yeah my own head right before I would
fight and he when he saw that he was
like okay I didn't know that's what he
had right away and I and I couldn't stop
I just did the aggression was just so
strong it was almost blackout right and
I remember my my brother was on the
football team and so he had all his
football friends they were standing
there they were like hey come on like
you know calm down when someone started
grabbing me that's when I started
freaking out because people were
grabbing me because I'm I'm like if he's
if you're grabbing me he has an
opportunity to come to the swing he's
gonna [ __ ] me up well this was during
lunch time at school and so the teachers
were coming from uh the Teachers Lounge
and they saw what was going on they were
like okay we'll we'll take it from here
and I remember this one teacher reached
for me and I swung at him and yeah and
he was the sweetest
like you killed it I know he was shout
out to Mr Green
he was a nice guy gentle guy history
teacher he's he uh he listened to reggae
every day like he his energy was just
pure he SMI like he smiled like he never
had any like he treated every student
with just greatness and I just decided
yo Mr Green don't you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
today
and so he backed up and was caught off
guard and then another teacher you know
if you listen to Hip Hop they would have
said this black kid's aggressive because
of the hip hop
it's the punk rock it's the punk rock
why is he aggressive
[Music]
you know he's pretty quick
he might not do that listen to reggae a
lot he's pretty damn fast I was like
whoa okay it was green all right
you know and I wasn't on Mike Tyson when
it came to swinging so but uh and then
another teacher grabbed at me swung at
her her yeah I know
man you were just go sorry Miss Johnson
my bad I didn't listen forgive me now
I'm better now because of it uh yeah
swung at her then all of a sudden I got
tackled we had a we had a buff principal
his name was Dr Hernandez Bluff dude
right principal tackled you oh my God
you tackled me he slammed me up against
the wall so hard
it was like and I try to like I was like
I knew what he did and I knew
I knew at the same time I was like I
can't let him just I mean he needed a
principal teacher whatever and so I
tried to bust back and then he was like
and I was like okay
you made it clear he definitely got 20
more years
and then he was like hey son I'm not I'm
not trying to hurt you I just want you
to calm down
my brother like I said this is protector
he he just started he walked up because
it was a big crowd around around campus
like watching this all go down on all my
brothers sees is me pinned against the
wall and my hands behind my back and he
saw that and he just
he saw red and he picked up a trash can
and he threw it at us and I'm looking at
him like at the principal in you all of
us because he was trying to get them
away from me and I said hey I'm over
here too yeah why are you throwing him
like don't don't grab a trash can just
come over here and pull them off yeah
and then and then that one flew by
everybody and everyone's just like whoa
and then he picks up another
trash can and I'm like hey
I'm like Damon chill
and so and that was the thing they were
like yo if you calm down and relax he'll
calm down and relax and I remember the
way they got him all like the his
football buddies had grabbed him you
know and threw him in a classroom they
like locked him in there to kind of come
they're like if you calm down your
brother will calm down I was like okay
okay I'll calm down and then they're
like we got to put your hands behind
your back we got a you know cuff you you
know to walk you to the who was there to
Cuff you uh we had a security then yeah
we have security and the police I'm
ordering we never had any of that they
would have to call him oh yeah they were
not they had to drive over from a
different building that was in the 90s
man nobody was shooting the [ __ ]
schools up in the 80s they were true
yeah so we had we had a campus officer
and then uh the security guard shout out
to Marissa she's a big white lady and
she did not play Marissa did not she was
she was she big mama okay and this white
lady probably from somewhere in the
midwest with the biggest calves in the
world did not [ __ ] play you see you
see her riding her bike around campus
[ __ ]
out this is like she look like Debo okay
that's that's how she rolled around
shout out to Marissa yeah everybody
talking to chain and when she would come
around bro I'm telling you I'm telling
you Marissa did not [ __ ] play would
she threaten the pepper spray me I was
like hey come on
I said we gotta do all that you gotta do
all that
what you want me to do you want to calm
down oh man she did not look and she
rolled into campuses
and did it and she was mean mugging all
the time like punking kids man it was
yeah that was Marissa shout out to
Marissa this podcast is sponsored by
better help when you're at your best you
can do great things but sometimes life
gets you bogged down and you may feel
overwhelmed or like you're not showing
up in the way you want to therapists are
trained to help you figure out the cause
of challenging emotions and learn
productive coping skills so you can get
closer to the best version of you we
talk about therapy a lot on the show you
know I'm a big believer in therapy
therapy is great for a lot of reasons
you know it's it's help it gives you uh
positive coping skills it's very good to
help set boundaries it empowers you to
be the best version of yourself alright
it's not just for people who've
experienced that's another thing people
love to compare trauma you know it's not
about comparing trauma whatever happened
to you it happened to you and that's
what you need to deal with all right if
you're thinking of giving therapy a try
better help's a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online you fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge if you
want to live a more empowered life
therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com honeydew today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash honeydew now let's get
back to the Duke but uh so anyways so
after all that commotion
um schools like they stop suspending me
and so
one school they they when they stopped
suspending me they made me clean up the
campus they're like you're gonna do
community service and I was like this
ain't the community this is school yeah
yeah I'm like what so I had to clean up
the campus and then this school so that
was my record of being suspended so much
and so they're like we're gonna put you
in Anger Management
so that's how I got at 15. yeah that's
all right and okay that's time number
one yeah all right now we go to anger
management where do we go we go to a
church where is this no it was on campus
it was one of the counselors okay and is
it a Saturday session like no it was
like uh during school it was during
school sorry
yeah so I had to do I had to do it uh so
it's like a class yeah so I had to do it
during school
and uh how many other people were in
there it was just me I only have I uh we
were the only kid fighting teachers
so because of how aggressive I was
I had to do the one I had to do one
one-on-one set shots I didn't do like
group sessions and as an adult with you
or is this like a a college student like
who's coming in to do anger no you see
there was a one of the campus counselors
the one the guidance counselors that
help you keep it in-house yeah they kept
it in-house but also I don't think he
really knew I was gonna see what he was
doing this thing
I'm like I see that textbook over there
yeah right
two teachers yes
[Laughter]
so I think your problem is I'm like you
don't know you don't know
uh so I actually stopped going after
that because I was just like this all he
kept saying was like you're angry I said
I know that that's why I'm here you know
but the second time I had to go was in
call uh junior college okay and it was I
was on the cheer team at the junior
college and I tried to fight one of my
teammates I said I told him I said
uh and it's funny I mean this this
should never come out of a cheerleader's
mouth
it's like I can't wait I said
[ __ ] you say something like that
to me again I stomped your chest in and
then I went after her
and then I went after him
and then everybody grab it because
everybody was like oh my God like this
is like I mean like you please tell me
you're in uniform and it's during a game
no it was at practice
so we had the pom-poms around and all
that stuff and it's just like hit some
cones over there and I'm just sitting
here trying to attack this [ __ ]
I said I said you say something like
that man I'll stomp your chest dude and
I would and when I went on attack I went
after him but luckily there was there
was another there was another
cheerleader on my team that was that was
a pretty big dude shout out to homie
Cedric uh he was a bigger dude so he was
upset yeah yeah and so he was able to
grab me and he had the strength to like
actually hold me yeah that Mr Hernandez
trying to hear that Mr Hernandez you
know and so he uh he so when he grabbed
me my coach was like they had to like
push me out cheerleaders yeah I know
yeah
laughs
what I said right here
and I don't even know what's funny about
the whole thing is I don't even I
couldn't even tell you what he said to
me that's what I was about to ask anyway
I couldn't even tell you what I was
angry about because a lot of times I
don't even know what I was angry about
but I just know if I just didn't like
disrespect and uh so principle yeah
principle yeah yeah the principal yeah
yeah the principle of the matter yeah
but I mean for probably what he said it
was probably so little
and and then my reaction was to stomp
his chest in
it was probably something something that
I'm like oh you you messed up the
pyramid today i'm like [ __ ] what you
know
and I just probably reacted but so my
coach was like you can't return to
practice
until you never have you in there yeah
yeah yeah and so she was like you can't
return to practice until you yeah and so
you do uh anger management and I was
like
so I
so this is the second anger management
teacher okay and she's at the campus
she's at the campus okay but she was she
was she was fully trained all right
because I remember when I walked in
there you know I walked in there I was
just like
you know just looking like that and I
walked in in her office and she was just
smiling the whole time right never
dropped her smile she was just smiling
and uh didn't have that pepper spray no
no no she didn't even see it yet right
yeah
yeah she didn't have big Marissa behind
her though and so she she uh
she just kept smiling and we said and I
sat down you know I still had this look
of like okay whatever and she goes uh
well my name is uh Miss Barry
um and I was like oh my name's Chappelle
nice to meet you and she goes oh that's
uh a beautiful name tell me a little bit
about yourself what are some things you
like to do
and I was like what and I've never been
asked that before like what are you
things you like I was like damn I don't
think anyone's ever asked me what I like
and I was I was like oh I mean what 19.
yeah right yeah someone that not one
person has been like what do you like
yeah because like I said earlier when I
was talking about it like I've kind of
just kept in my own world and I've just
and I just go these are the things I
like to do and I'm really happy doing
these things and I just stay there and I
I kind of just kind of
go on a shell
so when she asked that and someone
wanted to was intrigued to buy it but
intrigued by my interest and the things
that I liked
that was kind of cool and so so then I
you know the guard came down and said I
you know I'm a Cheerleader here on
campus I skateboard I also play guitar
she was like oh my God you play guitar
she's like oh wow that's that's amazing
um how long have you been playing I was
like oh I've been playing since I was
13.
um she goes and what's your favorite
style to play I'm like oh punk rock and
she's like that's that's amazing uh
where's your musical background come
from are you and I was like oh I'm the
only one in my family that that plays
instruments and she's like grandparents
or anything like that I was like oh I
was like I don't know my grandparents uh
too well but I don't think they have
like a musical background and then um
and she was like oh none of your
siblings or anything played like that I
was like oh no just just me you know I
was like I'm kind of like a lone wolf
you know when it comes to to that world
and then uh she goes oh wow so what what
did your what did your siblings like to
do I was like oh my brother was a
football player my other siblings they
kind of you know play the more
traditional
Sports as well and then uh then she goes
oh wow
um what are your parents like
and when she when she did that
I got quiet
and
and I was like oh I have my stepmom or
sorry my stepfather and my mom you know
that's all that's all I that I just said
I just grew up with my stepfather and
Mom and then um
tell me a little bit about them
what was your home like life if you play
guitar that you know seems pretty
exciting and then when she said what
what my home life was like when she
asked that question that's when I just
started swinging
I said you ever say so you asked me a
question like that
I told you what I told that cheerleader
I'll stop your chest and ask me a
question told you you can't say Dad
around me
you say the word dad I swear to God I'll
go crazy you can't bring up fathers
nothing
you just say adult in the house oh God
I I
that was the first time I ever spoke
about what happened to me
that was the first time I ever this is
if I'm doing the math right you're 19 16
15 16 years so 15 and then we went to
Junior College yeah like yeah like yeah
and you remember this vividly vividly
because it was because someone just gave
a [ __ ] yeah someone just simply said how
are you yeah how's your [ __ ] day we
forget that that really does make a
difference in people's lives you know
I'm guilty of talking at people for a
while too and not shutting the [ __ ] up
and be like enough about my ass like how
are you today what's going on with you
how's your health how's this yeah just
just a simple it was everything she
asked was just very very simple it was
nothing seeing the impact it made on you
yeah yeah you know like I said but you
gotta realize I I had a third anger
management I know I know we're halfway
there
but this one was a good start this one
was a complete she was amazing I have
I can't even remember his name yeah uh
but miss Barry that was that was he
remembers your ass
right now like this Chappelle kid I'm
telling you he scared the [ __ ] out of me
but no yeah she just asked these simple
questions and when I said my home life
was hectic I just started crying
and she was like do you know what do you
know what happened to you
and I was like no she goes you you were
abused and I said uh I was like I and
and then she goes you have you have PTSD
and then she broke down PTSD and I and I
and I stopped her because I was like oh
this I think that's for the War veterans
I was like I don't think I could have
um
PC PTSD that was like I think that's for
people that fight in the war and then
she was like and then she you know broke
down
post-traumatic stress disorder she goes
the things that happen to you when you
were younger are
triggering you know how you live today
you know or you know making you know you
live in a way of this aggression that
these things that you haven't
necessarily let go and I was like oh wow
once you broke it down I was just like
that's me I I never thought I was an
abused child yeah you know is that all
right I'm going I was like you know
where are you at now I'll go get his ass
right now
let's throw these hands now they're
sounding so good we're about to get to
the third one but I can't wait to hear
no it was like the third one was
actually pretty smooth okay so the third
one is easy the third one wasn't good
this was a positive how long did you do
this is it this one I was going to hurt
for a few months yeah okay and you liked
it you loved it great I would go all the
time and then I had this psychology
teacher named chip Chilton what chip
Chun Chilton not chilling no Chilton
chip Chilton shout out to chip uh I love
this dude it was the only teacher
where I just paid attention in class
where I sat there I didn't I didn't say
any words and I was I was so the most
focused I think I've ever had in the
class was Chip Chip's class because he
was so cool and every day before class I
would go and I shake his hand right just
just because he and even if he came in
late before he would start the class he
would go oh I gotta do something and he
walked over to me and come and shake my
hand all right and I don't know why I
was shaking his hand but I just I it was
just because I liked him and then one
day he walked past the session that I
was in and um
uh and what I saw on the next day I said
chip do you know the lady that I was
talking to and he goes uh uh no who is
that I go oh down I was like damn I
thought you would know because of
psychology and you know I was like
that's my anger management teacher and
then he said anger management
he's like you're in Anger Management I
go yeah I got it I got I got crazy anger
problems and then he goes
I would have lost a million dollars I go
what what do you mean he goes you're
angry he goes why don't I make you mad
why don't I make you mad and I was like
uh
I don't know you just Stone you're a
nice guy he goes why don't I make you
mad I said I don't know I was like I got
you I mean you asked I don't know and so
he goes I want you he goes he goes yeah
ask me again I'll stomp their chest out
he's about to take a chance I swear to
God ask me again ask me again go ahead
fix your mouth to ask me again
no but but he was like I want you to go
home and think about why I don't make
you angry and because I liked him so
much I actually did I remember I went
home that weekend I remember I came back
I said chip I did not know why I did not
make you angry he said you know what
come by my office around lunch time he
goes this ain't gonna be teacher to
student it's not going to be doctor to
Patient
um we're just gonna become friends I was
like okay I can dig that and so I went
to his office and I remember I walked in
and big rock and roll geek loved loves
Jimi Hendrix uh he had he had all Eric
Clapton had all this stuff in his in his
office I was like whoa this is this is
dope I was like I never thought a
teacher would you know get down like
this same questions tell me about
yourself what are the things you like
right you know I started to realize I
was like oh this is a traditional this
is uh that's how y'all do it they just
memorized yeah yeah yeah you know right
and so I told him I was like yo uh I
said I'm cheerleader on campus uh I'm a
big fan of punk and hardcore music and
it was all you like punk rock he was a
what's some of your favorite bands and I
was like why does it matter I was like
you're a teacher you wouldn't know he
was trying me and I said black flag and
not only did he tell me about Black Flag
but he also told me about other bands
from that era and I was like
what and then I was locked in
chip was he telling you about like sex
pistols and yeah he just broke it down
like that yeah yeah because and he knows
I'm a big Rollins geek and so he would
use a lot of Henry Rollins spoken word
things from that to help me with my
anger because he was like oh okay he
took my interest and used that to help
me with my anger and uh that was one
person
and I haven't seen him since I've always
and I've tried to like find him and I
hope one day that I do find him because
I owe so much to that man because that
was the first time someone had
like really seen me and didn't think I
was an angry person and thought of me as
like genuine and I didn't really know
that that was like fully in me but he
saw it before anyone else really did and
so when when he when he like
when he said I would have lost a million
dollars to think that you're angry I was
like with something on my chest it was a
bug on your microphone I was about to
tell you to smack the [ __ ] out of it
stop looking at it I want to reach over
there yeah yeah
but uh but it was so so me and Chip
would have these conversations all the
time and I remember one thing he said to
me where he was like I said I don't
really have a lot of uh confidence in
myself you know self-esteem uh because
of the way my stepdad treated me
and he laughed he goes what
he goes it was never his
he goes it's self-esteem it's yours
he's like are you with him anymore I
said no I haven't lived with him in
years he goes yeah
it's yours he never had it
you know and it's always going to be
yours it's never going to be anyone
else's and I didn't think I didn't
understand that at the time because when
he laughed at it I said chip laugh at my
[ __ ] again
I'm a backflip
it
was it was wild
[Laughter]
that was wild
and then I think about it now and I know
exactly what he's I knew I know exactly
what he's saying I know exactly what he
meant no it still affects me like my
self-confidence has always been good
yeah in the sense that I believed if
this was my job I could do it and do it
well okay if this is what I was supposed
to do I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do a
good job but I believe I can do that my
self-esteem
beat down right beat down but it makes
sense that your self-confidence is up
your self-esteem is yours also right so
I've I've always even still my
self-esteem is not where it should be
but my confidence self-confidence is
yeah you know I believe in myself I've
always have I said this before too like
going back to validation
um I never looked for validation out
there ever yeah I did what I did not to
prove anyone wrong but to prove myself
right I knew I could yeah I [ __ ] knew
I could whatever it was I'm like I know
I can do this [ __ ] I don't care what you
think I'm not doing it to be like I
showed you I'm doing it because the
validation I want and need is from me
yeah yes for me only time I did that was
once when my stepdad said I never
graduated high school I was like [ __ ] I
did it well apparently listen I'm not
saying it shouldn't be the third thing
on the list or even the second but the
first thing yeah yeah so Chip Chip
dropped a lot of knowledge uh my way and
like like I said he's someone
that I just owe so much to
because that was the person that pretty
much really like Miss Berry started it
she she like you know
crack cracked it open and then chip was
like okay
here's what you're gonna do you know he
he took the things that I like that the
things that I loved and just helped
guide me through these things to help
control my anger and he also told me
something he said your anger is never
going to leave he goes everybody has
anger he goes that's that's uh that's uh
human nature it'll never leave so don't
ever think that you won't have it that
you're just voila it's done you're
always going to have this he goes but
here's what you can do with it and then
once I realized that
I was like damn
because because he was like all you know
is anger that's the one thing you he
goes that's the one emotion you know
best you know it's so well you know
exactly where to go to get that anger he
goes but here's what you could do with
it there's a lot of positivity you could
you could do with this anger you could
use it as a drive a drive to help you
succeed in these these other areas of
life you know you can use this anger
to to study how to deliver a better you
know deliver a better better self and I
was like wow yeah motivate you to move
forward not to keep you in the in the
even in the present yeah especially not
the past that's what I'm saying because
so it catches a lot of people off guard
that I actually went to went through
anger management what was the third one
this disorder so Chip is the is the
third one he was actually your
management as well so he was he was a
psychiatrist or whatever whatever they
do with the the offices or whatever I
know yeah yeah like he he he did that so
he was
um and and you like that too then you
really yeah that means and he knew my
world so world of my world so well like
with the punk rock which was
something that I consider like a big
part of my yeah and you take that anger
and angst and put it into music yeah art
yeah yeah and and
like I said I I got to give so much I
hope I find him one day I really do
because chip yeah chip you listening bro
you know I haven't stopped anyone's
chest out in a minute
oh
you better make sure I know right
[Laughter]
protect your chest
oh man man that's funny oh I remember
one specific thing with chip that that
this is why oh this is why I owe a lot
to him
I remember one time I was with my
brother and
and I had and he he still talked to my
mom on the regular but he was he was old
enough to like he lived on his own and
remember he um
he was like man my stepdad just keeps
[ __ ] because she she she eventually got
out
but he he wouldn't leave her alone
and then um I kept hearing and I was
just getting mad and I wasn't even like
I said I
I don't know if like I I was so 50 50
with my mom I felt bad that like because
I I just hated him right and the fact
that he was just doing anything in
general the fact that he existed I I
[ __ ] hate it
and I remember
her brother said let's let's go do
something about it
I said I'm with it and he said we might
get crazy I said that's all we do
and I remember
and I and I felt it because I was like
man I think me and my brother are about
to really do something crazy
I felt it
and
this was uh
yeah I was visiting back home and I
called chip and said hey man
I said I just want to thank you
for every he didn't answer so I left a
message I think I said I want to thank
you for all that you
helped me with but uh
you know my stepfather is is still
give buck and I said um I'm lacing these
I said yeah I said I said me and my
brother
I said we got we gotta do this
I said it's been like like been a long
time coming
and so we got we got to take care of
this
and um
I mean recalled immediately
and
like I didn't know what he was gonna say
but I answered I don't know what he was
gonna say
and I remember me and my brother again
literally getting ready to leave we're
about to hop in his uh as Jetta bumping
R B music because that's how I'm like
my brother would bless
we'd be in the car together just two
dudes just bumping Usher
Yeah with anger yeah you know get ready
to go drive up in the club
it was so he would always do that [ __ ]
I'm like why we always say fire me up
right here
he would always do [ __ ] like that
meanwhile he felt the anger but he's
just like man that's just cool yeah
ship yeah chip called and there was
something in his voice that I just never
heard from Chip because he was always
calm and very he spoke well
and he was like stuttering and freaking
out
and I said we're just gonna kick his ass
you know and he said I I don't I don't
want you to do that
he goes I want you to talk to your
brother I want you I want you to sit
down with him
um and
and and talk about why you shouldn't do
it why why you should not do this why
you should not go over there and do harm
do because he goes you're gonna harm
him but you're also going to harm
yourself
you're gonna you're gonna harm you're
gonna harm yourself and your brother's
gonna harm himself as well you may not
physically do it to each other but
the repercussions of what you do will
happen you can't let him have this is
what he said that's what he said he goes
you're giving you're giving your
stepfather something
that
you know that he he can have of yours
he's going to have this thing
of you and it's not something you want
to give him
and
I remember thinking that
just I'm about to give him something and
I didn't want to give him anything I
never wanted to give him anything yeah
right and and the fact that I was about
to give
even if it was just you know a beating
I was about to give him give him that
and meanwhile things were about to be
taken away
for me he's going to he's yeah he's like
yeah he was in a sense like your
stepfather is going to take something
the the the law is going to take
something you're gonna get things taken
away from you
and I was like wow
[ __ ] and he had this rush in his voice
where he was where he was in a sense
like had just had
like almost like pleading
and I and it hurt my heart to hear
Chip's voice like that
because I know how he is and I know how
a beautiful person he is in such a
gentle soul
and to hear that I was in a sense
freaking him out
I was just like man
I said I can't do that
I told my brother
when I got off the phone with chip I
said we can't do it
we can't we can't go over there
we we just got we got to be better than
that
we'll figure it out things will work out
we we but we we can't we can't do harm
we can't hit
we can't we can't we can't do it and
and he he was like
all right just like that as simple as
that
and I think that was the first time I
ever
probably just I don't know if when my
brother felt for me at that point
and I didn't even say I just talked to
my anger management teacher but I don't
know what he felt he felt something to
where he was just like
okay and I don't know if it was just
because
he was someone that always just backed
whatever like he's supporting you this
way too yes right and I think that's
what that was and I never got to really
ask him about it obviously you know
through this passing there's there's so
many things I wish I could have asked
but you know do the unfortunate events
but I think there was something where
yeah he was just like yeah all right we
won't do it
sure
what's you you know and I and I just
said you know
because like I said I was I was visiting
uh
uh like I said I was visiting home from
from college or whatever and so I just
said just just be there
for Mom just do that as best as you can
and
yeah and yeah we didn't do it
but today if he did it again bro
ready
protect your chest protect your chest
from me dog dude I'm proud of you man
you got a long way to go too that's what
also sucks is like now you're in it
you've accepted it and then shit's gonna
be circling back all kinds of emotions
pop up and you least expect it then you
maybe become a dad then you got feelings
about being a dad and you're a dad and a
stepdad and this stuff oh man well
luckily I am I've I've become at peace
with uh my stepfather and I feel bad
because people feel like I should hate
them and they want to talk bad about
them and I I don't want I don't want
people to do that it's just not good
energy it's not the energy that I want
to put out there I agree uh like I said
I I mean I have his number I'll call him
up right now you know to be like I I I
would rather
you know because at times when I do talk
about my stepdad people are like I you
know [ __ ] him and I'm like no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no I
don't want that I don't want that energy
I don't I don't want to put that towards
this way I'd rather him be better I'd
rather him you know
uh learn about life in a way that I got
the chance to learn I'd rather that I
don't want this like yo [ __ ] this dude
or anything like that I don't I don't
want that energy put out there about him
because I'd rather
you know especially because I've seen
the result of
all the things that like
I've uh been able to learn there's
there's a beautiful result yeah there is
from it and and it's never too late for
him you know I think he's 52 now yeah
he's 52. because he was he was 17. when
I was born yeah I was gonna say yeah he
was young a few years old yeah so that's
what I'm saying he was probably just
thinking all the time this is my little
brother yeah of course I hit him you
know saying like he's probably thinking
like this I don't know I don't know
he's been in my life since I mean
actually like present like how long were
you under here that [ __ ] never
left the house God damn I was like bro
but you didn't use your life oh no no
I'll wait until he kicked me out
but like I still see him yeah you know I
still see him like he lives in the same
area you know look man I appreciate
coming on and talking about this it's
important because there are so many
especially us guys too that are angry
pissed off
um and then we end up doing something
especially when we're young and dumb and
yeah we think we're bulletproof and then
you end up going into this system that
doesn't give a [ __ ] about your story
because what you also don't realize is
even though maybe like I knew for me
nobody else in my circle or even
proximity was living any story like I
was living but put me into the [ __ ]
system I'm a dime a dozen and I'm a
dozen right in the suburbs yeah but in
the system nobody gives a [ __ ] about no
one's there because you've become a
number there so you gotta stay out of
that be the [ __ ] outlier in the
goddamn suburbs yeah be that one yeah
I'll be that guy yeah you know yeah but
if they get if someone gets Buck you
know they gotta get their chest kid
um dude thank you for coming on again
thank you thanks for having me again
everything again please yeah uh yeah
January 5th through the 7th I'll be at
punchline Sacramento all my Social Media
stuff uh at Chappelle Lacy uh I don't do
any podcasts and stuff but I post you
know clips and all that on my socials
and I would love nothing more than for
people just to see me see me live you
know all right yeah so go see him live
uh guys thank you again for your support
make sure you subscribe up to that
YouTube Ryan sickler.com Ryan sickler on
all your social media we'll talk to you
all next week
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]